two parts have you heard the term alpha
female and women are referring to
themselves that way and do you feel the
same negative reaction about alpha
female as you do about alpha male that's
a really good question i think that
some women in the states and this is
something i've noticed because i i'm
foreign
um even though i don't sound foreign
i've noticed that a lot of women here
are so
um
they're so intent on being these strong
independent women and they kind of
ignore
some of the things that could possibly
make them very happy because of it some
women are really predisposed to be
better at being alpha females and some
women are not but um
for me i'm a very independent woman i'm
very strong but i recognize that the
things that i'm attracted to
um
or the way that i'm predis positioned to
be is very nurturing loving caring um
and it's okay to recognize that i think
some women some women uh how do you say
[ __ ] sorry
how do you say um
they push it away
resistant averse they resist okay yeah
they're averse to it even though it's
their natural inclination
well said do you think that the alpha
like does it give you the same
like we hate the alpha beta thing like
that like disgusts us but when you hear
alpha woman is it like go and get that
bag no you don't think so no i don't
think so what do you mean go and get
that back like ghosis like killing it
when you call a girl an alpha woman
because the viewer was asking like do
you feel the same way about it for like
between genders i think it is really
different if an alpha if if a guy tells
you he's an alpha male yeah like you
were just saying a second ago like oh
i've never met a guy who calls himself
an alpha male actually be an alphabet
that's correct but when a female says
i'm an alpha female does that give you
that same do you like go oh yeah it
makes me think that they're afraid of
forming connections with the opposite
sex they make and i think it's the same
with men by the way who say they're
alpha males i think that they enjoy the
company of a woman physically but i
don't think they enjoy having
conversations with them i think it's the
same with women who call themselves
alpha females we need each other
we have to recognize that we need each
other some people might be better having
the woman be the provider and the man be
the nurturer doesn't matter but the
general population is not that way and
it's okay to recognize that and to uh
lean into it i've never heard a woman
call herself an alpha female however
i will say i've heard lots of countless
women say i'm a bad [ __ ] all my bad
[ __ ]
is that the same thing being a bad [ __ ]
you could argue independent is alpha too
see the the and i know where that guy
was going with this is yeah i get this
all the time because like like women
will say oh i would never get with a guy
who calls himself an alpha male he's
using it unironically that's why
that's why i had to make the distinction
but think okay how about a high value
male how about captain america versus
iron man whatever
when i talk about those things there are
so many podcasts and so many shows
saying oh the alpha male has been
debunked and here's here's why and
here's the studies and everything else
and those are the same people that if a
woman comes in there and calls herself
an alpha female they're like oh yes of
course there's an alpha female yes yeah
you go girl that's what it ends up being
so there can only ever be an alpha
female but there's no such thing as an
alpha male and i'm like that to me it
says more about the mindset of the
people who are describing all of this
than it does about the actual definition
or the actual abstraction that is alpha
so my my point was this is that there's
no such thing as an alpha female there
is only alpha men so the things and the
qualities the attributes the
characteristics that make a woman
independent she's got her own business
she's got her uh her degree she's got
and then
you know statistically speaking more
women are in college more women are
earning more money um
there's
from a numbers perspective this is all
backed up but when
women can't get the guy that they want
to like maybe they're nurturing right
they want to embrace that that feminine
side but they can't get to it because
for the better part of their lives
they've been turned into the men that
they want to marry they are the alpha
male with tits and vagina that's what
they are and so they'd wonder well
where's my guy where's the guy who wants
to be my equal partner and go off into
you know into you know family
land and have babies and everything and
they find that the guys that that would
be their equal or be higher than them
don't have anything to do with them
because they're not feminine those guys
are looking for women who are feminine
women and that's the number one problem
that i deal with right now when i'm i'm
dealing with uh like when i'm counseling
women is like okay rolo i can't find the
right guy where you know she's like in
her 30s or whatever and i'm but i did
everything right i did everything
society ever told me to do i went to
college i got my my degree i've got um
i've got my uh my business going for me
i gotta freeze my eggs because i can't
find mr right
and
they're they're building themselves up
into this alpha ideal but that ideal is
based on a male archetype the real alpha
female is the one it's not sheryl
sandberg from from facebook it's renee
summerfield it is the it's a
the swimsuit model okay because that is
the the apex of femininity that's the
that's the highest top of that that
pyramid that we're looking at for
femininity so if we're going to define
alpha or beta in a masculine or a
feminine term if you are a bad [ __ ] and
you've got your [ __ ] together and you
make your own damn money you're
basically a man
and men don't i mean generally
heterosexual men don't want to get with
other men boom let's just pause right
there for one second you said that is
the number one problem that you're
facing the people people when i'm
counseling women okay so i don't want to
skip over that if that's the number one
thing that you're seeing you're seeing a
30-something-year-old woman who is
relatively successful increasing and is
educated has not had kids yet and she's
the breadwinner in the family or no
family but she's doing her thing she's
quote-unquote a bad [ __ ] and she's
wondering why she can't find a high
quality man high value man that's the
problem
explain that exact thing
i did i did a show i did a recent show
about maybe it was about six weeks ago
um it was had steve harvey was on there
and some chick in the audience stood up
and she i think she was like 35 or 36
years old and she was there with her mom
and she was explaining that she was you
know did everything the right way she's
35 36 years old she stands up and she's
you know very religious she's like i'm
you know praying to the lord for the
right guy but i did everything steve i i
got my college degree i've got my my
money is down uh i think i'm a great
person i'd be a great catch and of
course steve harvey just kind of fumbles
through the whole thing but i'm watching
this and the reason why i used this as a
critique was she's representative of a
uh certainly a demographic of women
right now who are in the same boat they
don't understand why they can't find a
guy who is up here when they've turned
themselves into the man they want to
marry as it is i believe that's exactly
what steve harvey said is that you are
the man that you know you are the man
you want to get with damn and and that's
really and that's that's tough medicine
what's the ideal woman then well and so
here's my here's my point is the the
problem i run into is when i talk to
these women like for you for i have hope
for you you're 23 you're the same age as
my daughter by the way both these girls
are young attractive and smart so what's
your advice i was just saying you know
uh you know it's okay don't be averse to
the feminine right when we were talking
to a woman who's like 31 32 33 years old
and you tell her that and for her entire
life she's like um i'm i'm professional
i've done everything by the book i've
done everything society told me to do to
be a bad [ __ ] to be an alpha female to
be a strong independent woman
registered trademark
and now i can't find the right guy it
must be men's fault because they're not
living up to my expectations and my only
recourse is to say well you need to
feminize yourself right you need to get
in touch with your inner female or your
inner feminine like we always tell guys
oh you get in touch with your feminine
side or your emotions and everything
it's the opposite i'm trying to tell
somebody who is a
been masculinized to get in touch with
their feminine side and for me to do
that particularly as a guy it sounds
like i'm saying dumb yourself down be
dumber be because femininity seems dumb
to the to that particular you know
demographic of women and that's hard to
do so they're resistant and they're
averse you're saying what i have to say
yeah thirty plus you know usually you
ladies as being in your early twenties
how do you
how do i feel about that women just like
you said in the beginning of this
podcast you said that the part of the
human condition is
you need discontent you have to be
constantly passionate about something
women are the same way if that's
education
and in most cases it is there's a reason
that a lot of women are taking over
universities because we love getting
educated we love learning we love this
but we've we we've for some reason
feminism has gotten us to a place and i
still consider myself a feminist but in
america
it's gotten us to a place where it's
like toxic feminism in the same way that
there's toxic masculinity and and men
only want young women who are gonna be
quiet women don't want men who are gonna
who are gonna be um wait what's toxic
masculinity
um
the way that i would the way that i
would categorize the people that i was
describing before these like alpha males
who describe themselves as alpha males
wait so that like a definition would be
an alpha male is like the moment my
definition for toxic first of all toxic
masculinity is a term that i would only
use in very very specific situations i
think it's overused
but i also think toxic masculinity
manifests itself in a lot of young
american men okay
who are pursuing women in the wrong way
and then being frustrated by the results
because they just don't understand that
women are equal human beings to them
okay how are they approaching women in
the wrong way i think people who
listen to certain
radio shows
and
and what they're understanding is all i
need to do is flash my money
and
work out and
get a woman and if she's she's talkative
and she's arguing with me like they put
labels on women like argumentative or
masculine or you know this and then i've
been labeled all of those things
um and i'm i don't see myself as that
um so i think that the reason that they
see that is because they see women as
competition they're not they're not
comfortable enough with their own
uh
i don't know if the word i'm looking for
is masculinity but like their own
ability to to be a good partner
that they just want a pet instead of an
equal partner
[Music]
you